welcome back the holidays are here and
we're celebrating by answering your
biggest burning questions on everything
from gift giving to gift wrapping yeah
it's a very special drew and a holiday
edition
all right let's get started alrighty
then first up uh
dana
where's dana hi hi hi dina hi drew oh
you look so pretty thank you
so i'm recently engaged and i'm spending
the holiday with my future in-laws for
the first time okay uh and i'm really
struggling to find them a gift i don't
want to under do it but i have a
tendency to overdo it
i still want it to be special so what's
an appropriate gift to get for my future
in-laws
i like my i had this last year where i
had it was my first holiday with my
fiancee's family
wellington and i just completely leaned
on him i was like
i just met these people you got to tell
me what to do
um and so i would really lean on your
partner have you had the combo yet yeah
and he is also struggling on what to get
his hair god all right well then next
drew do you have anything well let me
speak as a person who tends to overdo
everything in life um i really relate to
the fact that you said that word overdo
it i think here's the good news when
girls or boys are dating at first and
you kind of overdo it with a gift i
think it can scare people off like
whoa you're too in and i'm still
figuring this out this is a different
dynamic right your
their family has chosen you
so you are being welcomed into this
family you don't the stakes aren't so
high about driving them away
but being you and showing them
why he chose you
um i love that's good that's great
really oh good i love that um i love a
little something engraved because it
just shows that you put that thought
into it um so whether it's a picture
frame or a little cat jaw something
engraved for me goes so far
i love that thank you yes
i love the engraved idea
i love anything engraved
all right up next where is it amanda
amanda over here hi amanda you look so
beautiful now you've got your
like gorgeous you guys look beautiful
so i am the queen of gift bags right i
throw everything into a gift bag but i
got my husband a vintage guitar and of
course it didn't come in a box so do you
have any suggestions on how i could wrap
this it's like a really weird shape you
know what i think you should do like you
know the car commercials where they walk
out front and there's just like a
gigantic bow on it right i think you
should like get a guitar stand right on
the wall and just put a big bow but like
sneak it out middle of the night so when
he walks in like santa brought it you
know what i mean i love it i love it
do you want to surprise it with him well
yeah i want to surprise him because i
picked it out special would you want him
to be deceived on what it could be like
whatever oh yeah he's like king of that
yeah i would love to deceive him so in
case you don't want to like do the
because i love the big red bow and i
think that's super inspired but if
you're trying to trick his mind i would
pick
a box that's really a different shape
than a guitar like a refrigerator box
like yeah even like a wardrobe box
something really deceptive and has a lot
of like newspapers and tissues wrapped
up so the whole time he's just like what
is this you could blow up balloons and
put them in there too totally love it
just literally go
for the full him route so that when he
finally does get to the nugget he's like
oh my god it was a guitar it was the
last thing i would have ever thought of
yeah so bo
or total deception
either way he's gonna love it yes it's
such a thoughtful gift good for you
thank you
okay last up is tina
tina where are you and what's your ques
oh
hi
what can we help you with today tina
okay i'm tina the baker and owner of a
small bake shop in hoboken new jersey
the name is baking mama
and every year i would come up with new
flavor cookies for the holiday season
but it's always a struggle for me to get
a catchy name or
to have a festive name for these cookies
just like what i brought to here and
it's just like peppermint cookie right
so right right
so it's just so basic that's what you're
calling it right now peppermint
so we could we can do better than yeah i
know so if you can help me name it i
would really like to see it right here
oh my god this is such a treat by the
way these are stunning tina thank you
thank you
look at this
i have a name but
it's raining mint hallelujah
[Applause]
you're welcome
it's raining hallelujah
the cutest can we also take a picture
with your cookies that you could put on
your website and then we could also put
you in our small business gift guide
thank you we're literally coming up with
all of this now but i think we can also
support
this cookie with ross and i and and put
you on our small business gift guide and
yeah did you know that our chocolate
chip cookie is named number one in new
jersey by yell
really yes
well we'll be sure to mention that as
well because that's a very good
marketing ploy good job all right we'll
hub up after this and all these ideas
are going to get cooked up and executed
well thank you tina thank you so much oh
for your happy holiday questions we'll
be right back
[Music]